no actually you know I did want to say
one thing uh I don't know which song was
on my playlist but there's there's one
great song during this match which
Really Got Me grew and there was this
like this Indian song I I don't even
know I'm sure people in chat will know
what it is but there there was this
Indian song which I started singing to
which was like the best thing ever it
was Chaya chai I think it was like
[Music]
that was like the greatest thing ever
that really that really helped me just
get get get grooving
um so I think at that time I was ahead
but that really got me into it so um the
I mean the Indian songs are great and no
wonder uh no wonder all these Indian
players are so good they should be so
inspired by their by their music